bon voilà on y est ça y est on y est
regardez où est ce qu'on est on est là
et où est-ce qu'on est là on est à rome
alors ça vous intéresse peut-être pas
forcément et ça n'a pas de lien direct
avec ce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui c'est
quand même bien d'être à rome la dolce
vita on profite regarder on est sur les
toits de rome et on est en train
d'enregistrer donc on les bat on my own
est là pour parler de quoi aujourd'hui
vous le savez vous avez cliqué vous êtes
au courant on est là pour parer d'un
nouveau smartphone nouveau smartphone
qui vient tout juste d'être annoncé par
au pot c'est qu'il ya dans cette boîte
là ça ça c'est le au pot fine x5 pro
alors il ya eu plusieurs modèles vous
savez c'est une gamme il ya le 5 pro il
ya le 5 et il ya le 5 light aujourd'hui
on va vraiment se concentrer sur le plus
grand modèle c'est celui qui va être le
plus payé avec lequel on pourra faire le
plus de choses parce que c'est celui qui
fait le plus de promesses et puis durant
une vidéo test complète dans un temps de
jeu vous êtes à venir vous abonner aux
attendes ce qu'on fait si vous cliquez
sur le petit bouton rouge si les rouges
c'est que vous n'êtes pas abonné vous
actionnez la coche et même si vous êtes
déjà abonné pouvait venir actionner la
cloche pour être notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera que ça c'est
vache on est alors aux parle de ce
smartphone pourquoi et bien parce que il
est absolument je pense sur le papier
incroyable par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
que sur les faillites ce trois pros l'an
dernier pourquoi sa polyphonie x 4 ol
parce qu'en fait en chine le chiffre 4
c'est un peu comme le 13 chez nous ça
porte malheur et on n'a pas envie
d'avoir un 4 arrive et ça veut dire que
si au pot avait fait au finepix 4 il
fallait 10 4 séries salue la motte se
serait probablement dit pas mal se
passer donc on veut pas se porter lâche
comme ou non va pas dans ses rangs on va
directement sur 1,5 un smartphone qui
est déjà ouvert que j'ai déjà une banque
c'est que j'ai la chance d'avoir avec
moi donc au programme de la vidéo on
prend on le regarde je vous explique ce
qu'il est capable de faire on va
également aller se faire une petite
balade de rome je vais en profiter pour
vous montrer un peu ce qu'on peut faire
très rapidement avec la caméra je vous
montrerai un peu plus tard dans la vidéo
également quelques photos pour vous
puissiez voir ce que ce smartphone peut
faire mais c'est juste pour donner un
avant-goût ce faire saliver les papilles
parce que dans un temps de et je vous le
dis on regardera sur le test complet ce
qu'on peut venir faire avec ce finepix
cinq pros et sur le papier c'est super
alléchant mais ça je vous montre tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis qu'à des mouettes regarder
la mouette ça c'est la mouette alors
j'en profite parce qu'on est ici et
qu'on aime bien celle à 20 kg et au
regard des jeux montrés très rapide non
ça c'est les toits de rome on à la rue
en bas au éviter de faire tomber le
boîtier il a plus un peu ce matin vous
avez du roof top vous avez des monuments
peu tous les côtés c'est vraiment une
ville que j'adore et je suis très
heureux de pouvoir venir ici faire
retour je profitais vient de prendre
quelques jours de repos de vacances
phare report pas réellement pour vous
emmener à rome va d'un petit drapeau
italien là allez on y va bon ça c'est la
boîte en retrait très rapidement regarde
parce que de toute façon vous allez voir
qu'il ya rien de bien lagos et une boîte
de smartphones tout ce qui est le plus
classique le smartphone doit forcément
je les enlever jeu les préparer pour
vous le montrer à l'intérieur on a quoi
eh ben on n'a plus rien parce que
monsieur doit tout enlever et ben ouais
j'ai tout enlevé mais vous retrouvez
normalement à l'intérieur ça ça c'est un
énorme bloc de charges signé au pot avec
d'un côté de l'usb de l'autre côté de
l'usbc ça c'est un bloc de charge 80
watts et c'est juste un monstre que nous
a faits au pot alors vous le voyez ici
c'est la super vous 80 watts vous pouvez
recharger votre smartphone en 80 voix
que truc qui est assez impressionnant et
assez dingue on est en fait ce que vous
allez faire ici c'est que vous allez de
rechange et à 50% seulement 12 minutes
alors ça c'est juste pour cette partie
hors charges extrêmement rapide parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'à l'intérieur vous
avez une batterie by cellulaire de 5000
milliampères heures pourquoi lit
cellulaire parce qu'en fait vous allez
lire recharger c'est comme si vous avez
deux batteries de 2500 milles et en
période de chaque côté on a des reflets
vous le voyez ça vous permet de le
recharger chaque batterie indépendamment
et d'éviter de venir leur donne magique
de la recharge rapide tout en sachant
que vous avez également de la recharge
sans fil 50 watts et de la r vous qui
vous permet de recharger à 100% en 50
minutes si vous avez également de la
recharge l'inversé 10 watts et là ils
ont fait un super boulot là dessus et
hop on nous annonce jusqu'à 1600 cycles
de recharge sont venir l'endommager donc
ils ont poussé en fait la durée de vie à
80 % français en tout cas sur le papier
ce qu'on nous annonce et je trouve ça
vachement bien parce qu'ils ont vraiment
une techno de charges qui va être
intelligente donc voilà pour la charge
je commence par là je pense qu'un truc
est vraiment très très important chez
aux paumés truc qu'on voit et qui est
vachement intéressant et bien c'est ce
design reprend un peu les codes qu'on
avait déjà que le five x3 pro l'année
dernière voyez ce module photo qui est
complètement curve et le fait d'avoir
rien qui dépasse aucune lentilles qui
dépasse tout est complètement intégré on
est vraiment dans l'héritage là dessus
alors qu'un nouveau dos et un dos en
céramique microcristalline nanométrique
en fait ça veut dire quoi et bien l'idée
c'est d'avoir quelque chose qui va être
encore plus dur que du verre deux fois
plus dur que du vert s'était forgée à
1000 degrés et puis apporter vraiment
beaucoup de résistance aux rayures c'est
vraiment la promesse en tout cas qui est
fait ici par au port on prend pas pour
autant les traces de doigts donc ça
c'est vachement bien un smartphone qui
va être aux alentours des 218 g niveau
du poids qui existent alors comme vous
l'avez là ça c'est du noir brillant
alors c'est que ça a un côté un peu
argent où on voit beaucoup de reflets et
sinon vous l'avez également sur un blanc
céramique alors vous le voyez c'est
marqué ici là noir sur blanc je peux pas
vous le cacher les marques ea seul blade
sans la bévue une année avec les
smartphones de bonnes places et un vrai
rapprochement entre les marques donc un
seul blake vient d'arriver au niveau de
la photo chez aux propos c'est à dire
très très bien ce qu'ils faisaient donc
là on va voir le résultat que vous allez
voir c'est super super bien et qui monte
encore en gamme la partie photo et donc
co développé avec un seul blade l'idée
en fait c'est d'avoir un milliard de
couleurs ce qu'on avait déjà une
dernière c'est à dire que lorsque vous
ajoutez votre appareil photo vous avez
un milliard de couleurs qui vont rentrer
et vous allez avoir un milliard de
couleurs qui vont venir s'afficher sur
votre écran c'est vraiment la promesse
qu'on avait déjà l'année dernière sauf
que là ils vont encore plus loin ils
vont encore plus loin pourquoi grâce à
une puce au npa alors le mps avait viré
toute l'intelligence artificielle mais
en plus d'avoir déjà beaucoup de
performances parce que vous avez un
snapdragon 8 jonone à l'intérieur 12
igad ram et 256 go de stockage donc ça
je vous en parle histoire de vous le
dire et en plus de ça vous pouvez venir
augmenter la ram virtuellement voyez
vous avez votre 12 giga de ram et
prévenir les montées avec de la ram
virtuelle à laval virtual ça vient
puiser dans votre stockage donc moi je
suis monté au mac c'est à dire +7 giga
de ram donc j'ai déjà 12 giga de ram +7
ça devient relativement énorme vous
l'avez ici la voyez pas si c'est bien
clair et si vous le voyez bien 12 +7
monte à 19 giga de ram en tout cas
virtuellement si vous avez du stockage
de 10 po donc ça c'est assez marrant et
puis vous avez ce npa été signé au pot
directement alors le pays s'appelle
comment il s'appelle marie silicone x il
est grave est aussi là nos maîtres et
qu'est ce qui vous permettra de faire
qui vous permettra d'apporter de la
puissance de calcul et de l'intelligence
artificielle pour toute votre photo on
nous annonce une plage dynamique quatre
fois supérieur beaucoup moins de bruit
dans l'image une meilleure reproduction
des couleurs plus de détails également
dans les parties sombres et dans les
parties claires donc ça c'est vachement
intéressant et on le regardera une fois
de plus lors du test alors qu'est ce
qu'on va retrouver au niveau de la photo
mais on va retrouver voyez vous avez
trois capteurs un capteur principal fait
en grand angle de 50 méga pixels afin
que vous sur notre grand temps où votre
ultra grand temps que vous avez dans les
deux cas ce 50 méga pixels sur le grand
entendons-nous bref un point c'est son
ultra grand-angle on ouvre à f 2.2 cd
capteur de 2 micromètres et on peut
faire du cas de pics au lendemain du
pixel binding on y regrouper vos pixels
et ça permettra d'améliorer notamment
les photos nuit et je vous dis si on
nous promet un milliard de couleurs et
puis vous avez un tel objectif c'était
l'objectif qui est planqué là avec le
zoom optique x 213 mégapixels touvre f
1.4 avec également un milliard de
couleurs alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on a cette fameuse inventif
reform qu'on avait déjà vu l'année
dernière qui avait été présenté sur le
fan x3 pro qu'on retrouve une fois de
plus sur un ultra grand angle pour la
première fois vous avez une
stabilisation optique 5 axes sans votre
grand angle c'est à dire trois axes sur
le capteur et 2 accent l'objectif anti
tremblement jusqu'à 3 degrés donc ça
autant vous dire pour moi c'est un truc
qui me plaît beaucoup d'objets un
tremblement essentiel vous donnez un
smartphone déstabiliser ça c'est une
promesse qui me plaît énormément donc on
regardera une fois de plus si la
promesse est tenue très rapidement il ya
notre boulot qui a été fait au niveau de
la partie photo c'est qu'ils ont mis une
lentille en verre lentille en verre qui
va améliorer la fidélité des couleurs et
qui va retirer 77% d'aberrations
chromatiques et puis à l'avant garde et
vous la voyez elle est là elle est
planqué juste ici vous avez une caméra
de celle fils une 30 2 mégapixels ouvre
à f 2.4 avec un capteur est une matrice
en rgb w alors ça permet quoi saas
permet d'avoir plus de lumière plus de
texture plus de détails une meilleure
plage dynamique il également propulsé
par le npa marie silicone x et vous avez
un changement d'angle automatique
regardez je vous montre sur la caméra de
celle ci voilà on voyez là là vous avez
un changement donc pour échanger
directement envoyées sur du 80 ou 90
degrés bon c'est assez marrant vous avez
déjà plusieurs modes dans la photo la
vidéo vous avez des chiffres avec castle
blais vous allez avoir le mode xpan qui
va être en mode signée vraiment à seul
blade en fait c'est pour reprendre à
leur style photographique alors je sais
que j'ai beaucoup de reflets mais comme
je ne suis pas dans le studio j'ai pas
des conditions optimales mais ça permet
quand même de se rendre compte on va
avoir un style photographique vintage
iconique d'un seul blake un format
étendu en 65 24e donc ça aussi on va les
tester et on regardera ça sympa et assez
intéressant pour des créatifs qui
veulent avoir un truc un peu différent
je vous ramène dans ma chambre d'hôtel
au moment où ton de cette vidéo celle
soit j'ai shooté d'une cuillère des
heures des heures et des heures avec à
ce nouveau smartphone qui est juste là
il joue montrait rapidement quelques
petites photos c'est vraiment pas un
test c'est vraiment un premier geste
ward se rencontrent à d'autres atouts
qui sont très très très sympa et je
voulais commencer à partager avec vous
notamment cette photo là sur le grand
capteur principal de 50 méga pixels
regardez vous avez un soleil de plomb on
voit t'oublier en avant il ya une
gestion de la plage dynamique qui est
absolument incroyable et qui marche très
très bien on va aller sur l' ultra
grand-angle et c'est pareil ça reste
quand même vraiment vraiment pas mal on
peut venir se rapprocher après et je
monte très rapidement donc il ya ça
aussi très rapidement cette statue que
j'ai été shootée à rome alors les
conditions sont vraiment vraiment
optimales on passe sur l'ultra grand
temps que l'on voit qu'il ya pas de
déformation grâce à la lentille freeform
ça marche bien c'est très très bien on
peut venir se rapprocher et lorsque je
me rapprochais reconnaissent et le
visage il m'arrive c'est un portrait et
voyez ça marche alors on va pas aller
trop trop loin dans l'image mais déjà
comme ça je trouve qu'il ya une très
très bonne gestion de la lumière voyez
c'est pas cramé c'est très très bien
fait autres photos histoire de se mettre
un peu dans le bain de l'ambiance
romagne le colisée qu'on passe ensuite
sur l' ultra grand angle où on peut
venir également se rapprocher et voyez
que alors lorsque c'est trop près c'est
pas terrible c'est normal mais voyez
comme ça la cedh gestion de la lumière
est magnifique sur le grand-angle sur
l'ultra grand temps une vraie cohésion
au niveau à des bleus dans le ciel on se
rapprochant un peu en froid 3 est en
froid 5 c'est vraiment bien en froid en
fois en fois 3e puis en fois en fois 3
et puis une dernière image que je
voulais vraiment vous montrer c'est le
mode xpan un seul blake qui un format
qui est très à part mais que j'aime
énormément et que je trouve vraiment
très beau il ya plein d faire garder ça
dans le dans le forum romain c'est voilà
c'est juste magnifique et ce format est
vraiment somptueux alors on s'arrête là
et on verra tout ça lors du test pour
une fois de plus venez vous abonner
comme ça vous saurez tout et puis vous
avez également beaucoup de promesses qui
sont faites au niveau notamment de la
vidéo
nuit 1080p et 720p ou alors carrément de
la 4 car avec une réduction du bruit
meilleure reproduction des couleurs une
plage dynamique qui va être plus étendue
en tout cas c'est une fois de plus la
promesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très rapidement je monte de 3 petits
extraits vidéos qui sont prises avec le
smartphone avant le test on regardera ça
plus tard là on est bien évidemment sur
la caméra principale c'est le
grand-angle rabon la gelée sur une
petite perle donc halal grand temps que
maintenant c'est du très grand angle ça
c'est l'ultra grand temps donc on va
venir forcément taper un peu plus larges
moyens comme ça alors après je peux
prendre la télé objectif je peux venir
filmer en fait à deux lorsque je vois
c'est que c'est extrêmement bien
stabilisé voyez ce n'est pas d'un coup
je peux y aller en plus peut venir
vraiment zoomer et là c'est très très
très d'ouvriers x 3 x 4 face à un creux
10 ce camp x 20 nm landes déplaçant ça
reste extrêmement doux et la re
désormais en des zooms en dézonant des
zones ont des noms des noms des noms d
où une fois au plat on sent les petits
claque la voyez quand on change de
capteurs regardez là je suis fois 06
vais me rapprocher app-line tic la voyez
lorsque se passe de change de capteurs
up l'attention va se rapprocher
up et lorsqu'on va encore up l'heure
n'est changé de cap travailler ça décale
légèrement dans l'image voilà ça a
changé mais c'est hyper double c'est
vraiment bien stabilisé ça c'est
vachement marrant venir se rapprocher
dans les saletés l'objectif et le
résultat est quand même la bomba est
trop près parce que c'est pas offert
s'annonce bien là ça prenait là dessus
c'est très bluffant et à main levée un
sans aucun problème et moi qui tremblent
à vasco assuré que c'est quand même
vachement bluffant et puis là vous avez
la caméra c'est hier s'est pas stabilisé
à lhassa bouge déjà donc lâché en large
et l'aj auxerre a très légèrement mais
il n'y a pas de stade donc forcément ça
va être moins bon c'est vraiment un
premier jet donc on se regardera plus
tard le détail et lorsqu'on sera le test
mais bon voilà c'est ça se donner un
petit aperçu allez on sent vite fait la
caméra nuit comme ça rentre ça raconte
on est dans la rue à rome c'est vraiment
les premiers tests et parfois dans le
sang la caméra principale au foot cela
sur l'ultra grand-angle puis là c'est la
caméra de ces le fit vraiment histoire
de se marrer tester c'est vraiment les
premiers premiers jets comme ça on sera
le test bientôt
l'expérience logiciel on la connaît ces
colorants est ce qu on reste 12 points 1
qui est basée sur l'android 12 alors je
vous ferai une vidéo très bientôt pour
vous présenter coloro s12 12.1 c'est une
expérience que j'aime bien que je trouve
vraiment intéressant très complète avec
beaucoup de personnalisation ça c'est un
truc qui est vraiment aussi génial au
pelage accepte tout regarder lorsque je
vais venir démarrer j'ai un fond d'écran
dynamiques vous aurez peut-être pas
forcément compte vraiment ni un plat
regardez-la fond d'écran dynamiques qui
bouge on peut venir personnalisé
beaucoup de choses que ce soit l'état il
les forme d'icônes les couleurs
l'affichage les animations au niveau du
capteur d'empreintes digitales ou tout
ça également on le regardera le all ways
and display et puis je dirige qui nous
intéresse réellement c'est cet écran
cette dalle ya toujours un très très
gros travail qui fait ici par au pot
déjà on a une protection à l'avant et
corning gorilla glass virtus donc
résistants absolument aucun problème 6,7
pouces de diagonale c'est quand même une
vraie dalle sénat il est très longue
mais j'aime bien ce format légèrement
incurvé sur le côté on a cette petite
caméra de cette fille là on a une vraie
symétrie focus entre les bords sur le
haut et les bords sur le bas c'est une
dalle amoled ces deux vieux ltp haut on
est sur une résolution wqvga des plus
regardés on va venir ici je vais vous
montrer un petit peu affichage et
luminosité vous avez le moteur 0 ultra
vision pour venir améliorer la netteté
prévenir active et amélioration de la
couleur de la vidéo la seule résolution
je me suis mis en full hd plus regardée
mais on peut monter en w qhd plus alors
forcément nous l'indiquent attention ça
va venir consommer davantage si vous
passez en qhd plus ouais allez on se le
fait on et des coquins on veut tester et
il n'y a aucun problème donc à venir
pousser la résolution très facilement
vous êtes sur un taux de
rafraîchissement adaptatif vous êtes
sûre du 1 à 120 hertz regard des
actualisations de l'écran donc là je
vais pousser jusqu'à 120 hertz le 1 ça
va être pour le all ways and display
alors l'intérêt de l'adapt à tisser
qu'effectivement lorsque vous n'êtes pas
en train de jouer que vous n'avez pas
besoin de sang myers mais si vous
regardez un film vous serez en 25 images
par seconde celui qui va le gérer de
façon intelligemment mais s'il voulait
venir économiser vous repasser en
standard et vous enlevez le wqs des plus
vous passer en full hd plus et là vous
allez venir à gagner en termes
d'autonomie ça sera déjà pas mal il ya
un écran qui surtout hyper hyper hyper
hyper hyper lumineux là je suis en
extérieur il ya plein de lumière et on
peut avoir un pic maximal jusqu'à 1300
dit ce qui est énorme et là vous voyez
on voit bien lors il ya des reflets bien
évidemment dans le reflet de la caméra
qui est juste là mais celle ci a juste
au dessus de moi et je vois très bien
donc ça c'est vachement cool et pour le
gaming j'ai un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile qui va aller jusqu'à 1000 r ce
alors maxime à l'intention des six
éléments du max 1 milliard de couleurs
je vous le dis du 10 bits et un écran
certifié agir 10 plus est au niveau de
l'audio on a deux haut parleurs un haut
parleur qui est située sur le bas ici et
vous allez avoir le haut parleur ici qui
servira également de renforts et je vous
donnerai mon résultat bien évident lors
du test très très prochainement on a
donc une expression stéréo et puis si
vous voulez venir brancher un petit
casque ici vous avez du bluetooth 5.2 on
a bien évidemment du wifi 6 de la 5g ou
sans doute ravi que sa dragonne 8 de
première génération de la estime un
smartphone qui est certifié ip67 donc il
ne va pas créer de l'eau et là j'ai eu
un petit peu d'eau sur la tête parce
qu'il ya un petit peu d'aujourd'hui un
peu de plus à rome donc ici pas de
problème et vous avez un système
d'antenne intelligente tout autour du
smartphone pour toujours venir capter
quelle que soit la position de votre
main que vous soyez en train de bloquer
signal ou pas faut qu'une vraie
répartition à 360° au niveau de vos
antennes pour venir capter le réseau et
l'a7 vous avez des gestes aérien on va
regarder ça aussi lors du test il ya eu
tout au travail algorithmique qui vous
permettra de bien venir capter lorsque
vous sortez d'un ascenseur lorsque vous
êtes dans un train avec vous captez mal
enfin bref un vrai gros boulot qui a été
fait part aux policiers que ce soit au
niveau matériel que ce soit au niveau
logiciel pour avoir un smartphone avec
un rendu maximale pour venir captées
pour vous faciliter la vie c'est que ce
soit totalement transparent pour vous
donc l'idée en tout cas je trouve assez
alléchant je trouve très intéressant je
trouve que ce smartphone intéressante
lui faire regretter papa aimé mais
regretter c'est que faisait enlever ce
côté microscopie que je trouve assez
rigolo qui est un peu what the fuck
l'année dernière même si je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on allait tous faire des photos
avec le côté microscopique on a
néanmoins de la macro mais ça on le
verra également lors du test qui
arrivera très prochainement et c'est un
smartphone qui coûte
1299 euros 90 et c'est un smartphone qui
sera disponible à partir du 24 mars donc
très bientôt mais d'ici là vous aurez vu
le test vous saurez tout donc ce sera
très facile pour venir vous décider
voilà vous savez tout sur ce nouveau
smartphone de au pot le finepix cinq
pros on se parlera très bientôt du test
on regardera le finepix cinq pros
encadra également le finepix 5 des
smartphones qui sont super aînés sont
restés connectés abonnez-vous s'est pas
déjà fait et si vous avez des questions
n'importe quelle question que vous
pouvez les poser juste en bas en
commentaire et j'y répondrai lors du
test en tout cas j'irai chercher des
réponses lors du test en tout cas à
prenez soin de vous et moi je continue à
me balader ouailles à rome on est plutôt
bien on va les manger des glaces allez à
bientôt tàu
[Musique]